hello everyone I hope you've been
enjoying my coverage of the world -
rabbit championship so far after that
long and brilliant endgame between
Vladimir fed of seven magnus carlsen we
have a wild game between Alexander
Greece Chuck and Safari Altai or maybe
it's L - I don't know he's a grandmaster
from Azerbaijan a very strong player he
won the other page on championship twice
in 2010 in the 2016 he was also the
under 10 world champion in 2002 and this
game this is a game from round 13 and
Greece Chuck shows us that no matter
what he will always be considered
amongst the world elite so Greece Chuck
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to f3 directly opening we have c5
and c4 transposing into the English
Knight to c6 Knight to c3 and the g6 III
by Greece choke Knight to f6 d4c
captures he captures and d5 seek after
Sun d5 Knight captures on d5 and Queen
to b3 attacking the twice the knight on
d5 we have E six defending the knight
and the Bishop to b5 Bishop to g7 Bishop
captures pawn captures Bishop and now
King side Castle by Greece choke castle
by Safari and we have Knight to a4
preparing to move the knight the c5 this
would be an excellent square for the
knight Queen to d6 rook to e1 now and
rook to b8 with a temple on the Queen
Queen back to d1 and Knight to e7
we have Bishop to Bishop to d2 Knight to
f5 and Bishop to c3 now defending the d4
pawn rook to d8 and we have night to c5
and this comes with a little trick
Safari plays Knight captures we have
nice to e4 now attacking the Queen Queen
to d5 and now comes knife captures on d4
Bishop captures on d4 and Queen to a4
and what's the idea behind Queen to f4
this is inviting Safari to capture the
bishop and c3 for example after Bishop
captures me captures now you have after
exchanging the dark square bishop you
have a lot of
dark square weaknesses around your King
and there's an immediate threat of
Knight to f6 for King the king and the
Queen so after after black defends
against this for example Queen to e5
now you captured the a7 pawn you win
back the pawn and it's a better position
for white so after thus Queen to f4 move
so far Lee plays Queen to b5 getting the
Queen out of the way so and also offers
the exchange of Queens he just grabbed a
pawn and here we have the grease truck
move he plays Queen captures on d4 and
Queen captures on before this Queen
sacrifice is actually the best move for
white rook captures Queen Bishop
captures Queen and we have f5 Knight to
f6 check King to f7 Knight captures on
h7 c5 and Bishop to c3 and if you look
at this position now
white doesn't really have a compensation
in material sense but if you look at
this strong diagonal this Bishop is
currently on from c3 he is protecting
the be to pawn you can never attack this
dark square bishop as you have a light
square bishop you have a rook and the
Queen so and Plus you have a seat bone
and be a pawn you don't have a beep own
or a deep on to attack the bishop so
this Bishop it can stay on c3 for as
long as it likes plus white Grisha has
nice doubled rocks this knife can always
jump to g4 g5 be supported with h4 so
basically it's it's a much better
position for white and additionally
Safari has a light square bishop and
this is practically useless in this
position so rope to b7 I'm preparing to
bring the rook into the game maybe via
roof d7 rook to e3
we have rook to e7 now and Knight to g5
King goes 3/8 and we have rook a to e 1
agree ship doubles up on the e-file and
piles up on that east 6 pawn we have E 5
by Safari and now comes Bishop captures
Bishop to b7 now the light square bishop
did become activated a3 now King to d7
and f3 not allowing any future ideas
with Queen to c6 maybe threatening some
checkmate on on g2
kink the c8 and we have Knight to h3
Queen a 4 and B 4 now and before is a is
a bold move district was a long time
pretty much the entire game but very
soon both of the players will play the
last 20 moves of the game were played
like both of them had 10 seconds on the
clock so it was it was really intense
and here actually capturing C capture
some before is perfectly fine for black
but in such a in such a time trouble you
have to see what happens after rip to c1
check the bishop is slicing all the way
here the King can't move the rook is now
covering the C file the other rook is
coming maybe to D file such as something
like King d7 you capture the pawn Queen
captures and the rook to c8 King goes
here rook captures Queen b1 check King
f2
now King captures it's it's a playable
position black black is actually doing
ok here the a pawn could prove to be
decisive here but you know it's in
serious time trouble it's very hard to
do to open up a file that goes all the
way to your king so c4 is plate and ok
your black has now created a passed pawn
Knight to f2 we have g v h3 f4 attacking
the rook rook to c3
now blocking the passed pawn bishop to
d5 Knight to g4 we have King - b7
King to h2 I mean to c6 and now rook to
d1 Queen goes here and this is actually
the move that I mean it's very hard for
for blacks to actually figure out any
sort of plan here probably a move like a
5 would be best break up break up
White's pawn structure here and it's
very hard to see if weif could make any
progress after that but here a Sephardic
played Queen to e6 and he'll out did
this Bishop to Bishop to f6 move this
attacks the rook and also comes with an
attack on the g5 pawn we have worked to
these seven and now Bishop captures and
on g5 also threatening now to capture
the DF for pawn and now those bones and
on the King side we should have will
start going up
the board and here Bishop to c6 was
played and this is a very interesting
move
Safari offers the exchange of roofs but
that actually favors grease chip an
interesting move here although it's not
a good move but an interesting move
would have been Queen to e2
it's hard to say if Safari considered
this for example Queen e2 you attack the
rook on d1 rook protects a rook and now
comes Bishop captures on f3 you threaten
checkmate on g2 and after rook captures
rook captures on d7 simply King to c8
and now you're attacking the rook on d7
and also threatening checkmate on g2 but
this actually doesn't work because
simply rook to c2 and white is winning
this after we captured the rook now
comes 95 check you force the King to
move away from the rook pink has to go
to be for example b6 and I will play
Knight captures on f3 there is no more
checkmate threat on g2 and over the rook
and 2 pieces for the Queen why it is
winning this but you know time trouble
it's hard to say if Safari even
considered this so after Bishop to g5
Bishop to c6 and now it's Greece to
cruise in the driving seat rook captures
Bishop captures and Bishop captures and
i-4 and now district 1 two pawns he has
3 passed pawns and on the Kings side and
also to connect the tones on the Queen
side probably if that a5 was played in
that position it would have been better
you know it's it's it's not a good idea
to have threats on both sides of the
board
Bishop to a4 we have rook to e3 and here
comes a series of moves that I really
want you to concentrate on
both players are in extreme time trouble
so rook to e3 Queen to d7 the Queen was
attacked
we have Bishop to e5 now not allowing
the pawn to advance as both Bishop and
rook are protecting c3 square bishop to
c2 and now comes Bishop to c3 blocking
King 26 and 9th to e5 and this is a this
series of moves I think it's six moves
and the Grisha plated them instantly so
what's the idea here
you have a lot of you know you don't
have a lot of time on the clock and you
have to
figure out the exact position you won't
have on the board and what are the ideal
places for your pieces the ideal squares
now we have here rook is protecting
bishop on c3 also is protecting the
knight the bishop is protecting the
night here and the knight and the bishop
are creating a wall here
d4 d3 and d2 so the Queen can never
attack the rook on e3 so now grace Chuuk
placed his pieces on ideal squares and
he doesn't have to worry is there maybe
a discovery on the piece or anything
he will next play King g1 King f2
protected the only unprotected piece on
the board and everything is fine for him
and another thing you have to consider
he placed all of these pieces on dark
squares because so far Lee has a light
square bishop so again there is there is
no move safar lee could make even if
greece chuck had one second on the clock
he wouldn't have to even think about
whether his piece will get attacked or
anything so a very useful maneuver to
master so Queen to a5 in a comes King G
one we have Quinta King to be 5 and King
to F 2 now even the rook is protected
and there is really nothing black can do
here Queen goes to g5 now b3 now Grisha
is preparing to start pushing his King
side pawns Queen to f5 we have King G to
Bishop to d3 and h4 now now the point is
rushing up the board here hair is hair
is going to win the game
King to a four we have h5 King to b3 now
Safari wants to kick that bishop away
from c3 and start pushing his own test.c
pawn bishop to d4 kink the c2 we have h6
Queen has to block the past pawn Knight
to g4 now defending the pawn king d2 we
have rope 2d six and I rocked a sec
sorry and this was the this end
I mean endgame there's still a queen on
the board but basically it's an endgame
and it was so intense every player in
the playing hall was watching this game
as it unfolded
even Carson was standing next to the
board watching it Bishop to a5 first
Bishop to e3 check we have King d3 and
all night to have to check
doesn't allow this Knights to be traded
King to see to now rook comes to c6 King
b3g for now and now the other point is
coming up the board is the world Queen
to d7
if pawn captures Bishop Queen captures
rook but rook comes to a6 Bishop to be
one now what is ready to support his
passed pawn down the board but rook
captures an a7 would attempt on the
Queen Queen e6
and outcomes Bishop to f4 c3h7 now Queen
has to block the queening square we have
King to g3 also defending the bishop on
f4 the Queen was attacking it
Queen 288 blocking and up comes b5 and
now there are threats on both sides of
the board there is nothing but I can do
here
Bishop captures a Mason a h7 was played
but now comes b6 c to b7 is here and
King to a 2 there is really nothing
nothing to do here
rook to e8 was played now comes Queen to
a 1 here so far Lee as their there are
both very long time was hoping for b8 b
8 Queen so he could maybe do some damage
with Queen to g1 check although not not
very likely the King will simply escape
there is no problems here but what a
cool head you know really those are some
steel nerves ungreased rook
he played King to g2 not allowing any
ideas for black here still if he promote
the Queen Bishop or simply capture it
and then promote he will promote his B
point to his own Queen and in this
position
Azerbaijani Grandmaster safar the L - or
LT resigned the game so a wonderful game
and a very refreshing one I mean it is
71 move but you know that that Queen
sacrifice was really really something so
that was the game I do hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here both of them will be of
course from the world rapid championship
feel free to suggest any game from the
World Championship I will check all the
comments thank you all for watching and
I will see you soon